on first order methods for thank you I
will present here some distributed model
for optimizing a network there I'm not
really as much concerned with
communications which most of the people
here have been focusing on so one can
reiterate and consider the aspects of
that of that issue so the idea here
would basically be if I have a
collection of nodes that are given in
some spatial kind of they're given in
some space each of the nodes may have
its own objective function that needs to
be optimized and nodes might be
connected in some work network I don't
have a picture for this so I'm gonna lay
down in work in layer in plain words and
the objective of the network itself is
to minimize the sum of the objectives
given to the nodes nodes are not allowed
to share the objectives but the network
is used as a community as a basically
medium for diffusing the information
that whole system can perform in the
desired manner so what do we mean by
this is basically in the network there
will be no central entity there's no
central node that will collect all the
information relevant to computations so
there is no master slave scenario there
is no access to the information from one
spot the there are various reasons why
we might like to consider that I'm not
going to go into great detail on that
but what I would like to bring into the
this set up is the fact that network
itself the communications could be
changing over time so couple basically
possibilities are maybe the network is
really static but due to do some kind of
protocols we are running not all nodes
talk to each other at a given instance
that would give rise to a time varying
connectivity of the organ agents or the
nodes so the goal is as I said that
we're gonna completely in a completely
distributed manner in a sense that every
node can operate only locally talk to
the neighbors we would like to design
protocols that will be robust to the
changes in the environment
and also easily easily implementable the
simple case it's also drawn very often
as a very simple kind of a set up
problem is that if we have a network in
which let's say this is a network
whether each node may have actually be
associated with some collection of data
and perhaps files an H node knows it's
average file you would like to kind of
design a protocol that nodes can talk to
each other and compute the average of
the whole network which can be cast as a
simple optimization problem as laid out
at the bottom here and the main point
being that here Teta eyes are the
average files that only theta is the
size of the average file that only know
that i knows and it's not willing for
whatever reason to share it may not be a
kind of a particularly interesting when
it's kind of this kind of setup but
theta I could be something else if it's
a simple average file maybe they can
exchange it but I'm pointing out that
basically I would like to do this
computation not knowing theta I other
than value is known only to node I and
then some algorithms for the doing that
have been proposed and one possibility
basically that is may be of interest to
these communities when you problems of
that kind can be also embedded in into
this support vector machine kind of
problems in principle centralized I have
a centralized problem where I'm laying
down object constraints explicitly in
many applications or models these
constraints are typically penalized and
brought into the objective it's some
kind of rescaling but in principle this
is the problem we are facing originally
the points actually within the
constraint set and one can fragment
these constraints basically turn them
into centers when each node will now to
kind of feed it into this framework
basically it can have a rescale version
of this normal norm of X which is really
like a regularizer here but and only
dealing with these crossings or
lacks of all the constraints that are
that that note particularly has
knowledge of so that it deals only been
a subset sub collection of the sets in
this case the the objectives is
distributed but also the constraints are
distributed if one wants to look at this
as a disability problem and here we
would not allow for example poor nodes
to exchange the data points which means
they are not going to exchange
information that is embedded in X I know
they are going to exchange the directory
information that is embedded in their
objectives but rather some kind of
estimates so what to do we what have
been considering you know I'm gonna get
get to a brief overview of this
consensus protocol and how they are how
that protocol have been used to kind of
solve this kind of distributed problems
so protocol consensus problem which is
basically very old problem had
considered the case where you might have
a set of nodes and each of them now has
its some initial value in the most
general setting of the problem the goal
was to design a protocol that will allow
no it's locally to talk to each other
exchange some values but not necessarily
there the initial values and they'll
come up with a protocol that will in
time produce basically asymptotic
convergence to the same point which is
basically alignment of the network on
the same value starting from perhaps
different initial values so there are
two versions of this problem one is
exact averaging where you wanna really
this limiting point X to be the exact
average of the initial points which is
known as average consensus and there is
a more relaxed version where you just
want to agree on a point but you don't
care what that point might be just any
point which is rather loose statement so
what this basically says that if I have
a kind of intuition that was driving us
here it is that if I have a protocol
that can align to a certain value
perhaps we can push this value into the
place where we want to go for example if
you are
amazing then you might be pushing this
point of interest or point of alignment
to some pre design objectives that the
network might have by basically playing
with this consensus protocol as an
underlying mechanism to diffuse the
information that you might like to see
that you don't know but you want the
network to know so it turns out that and
you can come up with couple ways of
defining this mechanism for the
diffusion is basically saying that if if
it is defined
perhaps the network might be changing so
let's say define by M sub I K here to be
the set of neighbors that a node I at
time k then what you are doing is you're
receiving these values from the
neighbors and you are convexity
combining them this here embeds just
basically averaging at locally at a node
I now under certain conditions here you
can write basically you can embed this
into a kind of a linear model this is
just a dynamic set on all die but if you
set these values to be zero for not for
those who are not neighbors you come up
with a linear dynamics and under certain
conditions on these networks you can
guarantee that consensus is achieved so
the conditions had typically called for
graphs to be let's say they're directed
to be strongly connected the matrices to
be lost elastic may may basically
matrices that you are constructing by
putting these weights into the matrix
form and zeroing out the know the
neighbors that are actually knows that
are not neighbors over no die for every
node in a network you can come up with
the basically the matrices become row
stochastic and but one of the company
typical conditions that were needed for
convergence of this protocol had to do
with requirement that the nodes that
basically if a node is giving away to
its neighbor then that way it has to be
persistent in time it can basically
saying that there should be some
positive constant so
all positive entries have to be
uniformly bounded for all the notes and
at all times and that was kind of in
essence mechanism to ensure that
information is properly mixing and not
losing overtime so key part that was
relevant to if you want to do anything
else on that kind of network whether you
want to optimize whether you want to
perhaps consider some kind of other
control problems or perhaps you want to
consider even some particular dynamic of
what may be associated with some social
networks the key element there for the
analysis of anything else you want to
build had to do with really defected
when you're looking at the rate at which
this mixing is happening over the
network the convergence rate is
geometric now the word geometric is nice
what we mean here is that really what
some people refer to linear convergence
basically for example here it says that
these different basically if you look at
the spread of the values of any two
nodes in the network so the max and mean
are decaying with a bit some factor
proportional basically bitter to some
factor raise but important part here is
that it's really decaying the time bit
is a parameter less than one
however this parameter itself need not
be favourable what I mean by that if the
beta is very very very very very very
large or very close to one you have a
very bad mixing so different different
now opening different structures in the
network can reveal much better constants
this is the worst case scenario so
basically this is very generic setting
and very very very basically constant is
extremely loose because it covers all
possibilities so what I wanna overview
now is this briefly what we've done with
this knot problem basically how we use
this to optimize and then in principle
there was one kind of key assumption we
were making that we would wanted to
remove and this is the one that I'm
going to focus much much more in a few
minutes so if you want to optimize in
this case I'm gonna skip here faster
because I'm running
one possibility to do this is basically
so the optimize this function over a
network let's say they have some
commonly known constraint every node
cannot work only with its own objective
function Fi and it can exchange
estimates so I'm assuming here that
estimates a finite dimensional possibly
vectors so the the this can be achieved
within like operating in two steps in a
synchronous model every node will first
collect information from the neighbors
and mix it this is like intermittent
step and we are basically looking at
consensus like step that aligns the
nodes in the network and the second step
is a really pure projection at each node
where each node just takes this
intermittent estimate the mixed estimate
and pretends it's only minimizing its
own objective function so the only
interaction of the nodes is here when
they are making these convex
combinations now under certain
conditions I'm gonna skip this it can be
ensure that such algorithm would
converge to an optimal value of the
overall sum function how can be that can
be done by basically laying down the
conditions that are pretty much needed
for consensus to happen and algorithm
and typically conditions you would need
for algorithm to of that kind to
converge so here if I'm not assuming
that the functions are let's say
differentiable I use the notation of the
gradient but I'm bearing in anything
possibility that these are sub gradients
then what we typically require these sub
regions abounded if I work with the
Lipchitz I would require or
differentiable functions I would require
some kind of Lipschitz and growth of the
gradient for the gradients and then on
linear growth for the for the gradients
and step sizes here also kind of what is
considered the slow but it's it's the
one we need for convergence because of
the network kind of impact there are lot
of errors in the system so you are
working with a very rare newest gradient
method and this kind of step sizes are
needed to kind of ensure stability
the process now the graph assumptions
are typically if I assume here that
graphs are only strongly connected at
every instant just to make it somewhat
easier requirement are still same as
this kind of us persistent mixing with a
positive weights for all neighbors and
at all times it's really this
persistency conditions for the diffusion
to happen but a critical assumption we
were making here is that the matrices
were doubly stochastic and that was the
critical for ensuring the statement that
the iterates that were generated locally
by the nodes which converge to a
solution of this problem the summation
of the other one of summation of this if
the weights were not doubly stochastic
we would here see basically scaling pi I
times a fiber PI I has to do with some
limiting steady state vector of these
make metric matrix product convergence
so I'm gonna skip that this was just the
Austrian I'll leave it out so too soon
to summarize because I want to go to the
main kind of extension that has to do
with removal of these stochastic doubly
stochastic weights is that critical
assumption was that we have double
stochastic weights on a supposedly
directed graph right that I was assuming
directed and strongly connected graphs
and this is one of the problems that
cannot be solved in real time it's very
complicated and it's np-complete
complicated problem to even determine
such weights on the graph so what we had
looked recently that came after
discussion with Mike and some of his
students that resorting to a different
consensus algorithm which was motivated
by work but dobra campaign Gerke they
are considering a some kind of linear
iteration algorithm to do that so for
the basic consensus part linear
iterations assume some kind of different
this form so what do we here have is the
graphs are changing and this sub J of T
is the
the degree of a node J including itself
so every then this is out degree so
every node knows how many nodes it can
contact outgoing on its outgoing links
and that's DJ including the fact that it
can talk to itself and this is can be
considered as X I of T is actually
trying to estimate what's the total sum
of X eyes at a given instant of time so
what's the sum of our values at a given
instant of time the next term is almost
as not trying to estimate how many nodes
are out there on the network so
initially it's critical to set this
value Y J at time zero to one because
the third instant node only knows about
itself so this is more like counting or
estimating how many of us are in the
network and this is saying how what's
the total sum of the values we have and
the true value that the variable Z which
is formed by actually ratio of these two
variables is the one that is going to go
to the consensus this is gonna go to the
initial average under under certain
conditions so when the node what is
there not doing here at any instant of
time naught will have some value let's
say X J I'm looking at node J or node a
J XJ and it at the time now it has value
X J of T that node will look down at an
instant when it needs to compute it can
look at outgoing neighbors and send them
this information basically its value
current value divided but it's out
degree it sends to every neighbor that
it can reach through outgoing links and
the reserves also that value for itself
now nodes node X eyes hear the downlink
neighbor whose does this mixing from
that information and coming from the so
node I will receive that information
from all of its incoming links and form
this and the same goes through YJ it's
just another variable that has to be
kind of combined in the same way
and then the Oh main difficulty with the
analysis of this algorithm is that the
matrix that you can construct now by
looking at these weights in the process
turns out to be column stochastic so
it's not in the prior case it was roast
elastic now it's column stochastic and
there is a slightly slightly more kind
of complication involved with the
analysis of those because for them we
get weaker Goudy City but not strong and
then the whole hurdle we had worked here
is to actually check what's the rate
where these matrices are going and it
basically turns out that by using some
kind of basic linear algebra analysis we
can estimate what's the difference of
this estimate of the average from the
true at the time average of the system
and that is driven by some expression in
which there is term that the decay is
geometrically and there is term I
considered here like a Runyon's kind of
case when we have a shift it's a murder
so there is a term that depends on the
error the purpose of this error is
actually to bury later if I want
optimization problem or perhaps I want
some control problem so this is the
drift bit sound field I can induce from
outside it's kind of on on a top of the
network I can induced another field and
as long as that because we are usually
controlling this with a step size this
is some kind of small in a sense small
after some time
therefore the what turns out that the
critical two values for the mixing
process at this Delta and lambda again
we are looking at a very generic case so
our predictions here are the worst case
possible one can look at the particular
details and find out models for which
this might the estimates could be better
intuitively lambda is something that
comes from the network basically could
be related to this second eigenvalue if
this was a laplacian or something like
that a delta here is something that's
not seen in the the prior is in the
first model as much Delta has to do with
kind of deep influence distribution
among the nodes what this means is
imagine that at an initially you give
each each node in the network power of
one and after this mixing of the
matrices it goes from let's say zero to
from eighty to a zero where you have now
column stochastic this is basically a
form of a distribution that will happen
at the end of the time T through these
matrices acting product of the matrices
acting on this initial power is equal to
one everybody and the delta is the
smallest power that agent could have in
a network basically the smallest value
that you would get from letting product
of eighty to a zero act on a vector of
all ones so for the particular networks
one can compute this in a simplest case
if the main this is just a simple
analogy this was the doubly stochastic
matrix that the power stays the same
because the matrices will be row and
column stochastic so it doesn't matter
to summarize I'm gonna just go to this
is a list of all the relevant work a lot
of work by Robert and his friends what
we can show is that under assumptions
that the graph is uniform is strongly
connected here the degree helps us to
remove this now a requirement of uniform
lower bounded kind of entries so under
assumption of gradient sub gradients
being boarded you can guarantee that
they all converge to a same point again
we optimizing the some of the objectives
and we can also provide the rate which
says that in the in a case of a rate
here we are using first step size that
is proportional to 1 over square root of
T and then to provide the rates we are
actually not using the Z's that the
agents are generating but rather we are
basically constructing the averages of
these iterates over time and the weights
that are used for these averaging have
to do with the sub size choice
we have seen these constructions in I
think even that the duality master of
method would also use something like
that
so at the end of the day we can show a
bound which at most interesting I would
say the rate is here actually a couple
of these terms depend on the ln of t
over square root of T in a very generic
no special structure Network no special
structure function so this is very
similar to the rate that du chí a gravel
and mud Martin why right had in their
dual leveraging implemented on the on
the network as well and this is coming
Ln of T comes from the mixing of the
network that we cannot there is a
particular kind of expression that if
one can do better estimate there it can
remove this a line of dependencies but
we didn't we couldn't do it this far and
this 1 over square root of T is just up
by product of the fact that we are
working with sub gradients with no
special structure on the on the on the
problem one can tighten this result for
strongly convex but the only thing that
changes is here
wherever square root 2 is playing you
can you can get 1 over T but Ln of T we
couldn't we were not able to eliminate
yet so as far as the communications go
this is certainly meaning this this
itself is more easily implementable in a
synchronous manner because the the way
the no-nose communicated could be
broadcasted simply so it's pure
broadcast to downlink neighbors and you
don't even know that where I wrote this
the triggering or the computations
appear to be at the same instant of time
you can easily imagine that nodes are
not doing anything which amounts only to
the mixing time that might have changed
a little bit so the what I'm trying to
basically summarize here is that
communications here are by far reduced
in synchronicity is not a key you can
come up with the algorithms that are
totally asynchronous basically by having
a random each node has a random clock as
long as these clocks are line
there is this even the step size here
that we kind of aligned can be also
taken out there is a way to basically
base this step size on the number of
times the node had woken up and they are
synthetically that would kind of behave
no different than this so you can relay
those to accept it it will take
definitely this analysis here will apply
to expected values and then you have one
has to worry about perhaps checking out
what's the variance with respect to our
probabilistic bounds that I can give on
on how long I need to wait for this to
drop down to be meaning like chebyshev
type of analysis can do that so in
principle I think that maybe something
here of interest to this community might
be because it is it is possible to look
at the communication complexity which we
haven't done and it's better than the
the one when we looked at the averaging
with the convex conveniences and I will
leave it at that there is we have a
report on on this and we had some small
simulations here this is not as exciting
we just take a simple Quadra h node got
quadratic function and basically we are
computing an average so you have X minus
theta and this is just the behavior of
the iterates of maybe one name one agent
in network of a thousand nodes here we
had something different on this line we
have how many iterations we need for
some criterion to be satisfied on the
y-axis we have the growth of the network
size which goes from hundred one
thousand two thousand twelve I think
here about eight nine thousand nodes so
we were increasing the number of nodes
using this basically giving randomly
assignments of this quadratic functions
to the to the agents and we took as the
criterion what we count here is how many
iterations we need it for this system to
compute the average within an error
let's say zero point one so it's not
higher requirement
we were more interested in looking
what's the tendency of how this time for
the accuracy would grow as to be
exploding the number of nodes and to be
honest this I'm not quite sure if this
is a linear growth or its square root of
n because I think we don't just this
segment of the curve does not give me at
least intuition which order is happening
Alex think thinks it's linear but I'm
not sure unless we have something on or
not kind of a theoretical side and with
this time I'm basically concluding and
I'm thanking you for staying till the
last moment
okay okay
no we haven't we haven't I say okay
because what the analysis is doing its
really independently looking at the
evolution of the numerator and the
denominator so I would think that I'm
not sure where the variance will hit us
because in the expected sense is not
touching us but when the variance kicks
then there will be coupling and I think
there could be some meaning I believe
under certain conditions you can get it
out because the truth is it's really
evolution of these two independently at
only at one place they couple so I think
it's doable
but we haven't done it